good afternoon reject nation it's Greg
Alva here and I'm John son of Humphrey
we're gonna talk about through Ragnar or
non spoilers today but before we do that
we wanted to give a shout out to today's
video sponsor and that is Stardust
Stardust is this brand new app that a
lot of your favorite youtubers are using
including Jeremy Jones John rogue late
to the party schmoes though a whole
bunch of people are using right now and
what this app basically allows you to do
and it's perfectly suited for what John
and I love to do you can do 30-second
reactions for any film TV show that
means any episode of any TV show or even
a trailer and you could post your
reactions you can leave comments on it
too can even safeguard against spoilers
but we also made a promise that we would
feature some of your guys's Stardust
reactions to Thor Ragnarok so here you
go
just see door Ragnarok in the [ __ ] is
fire man Taika Waititi has completely
just blowing it out of the park it was
okay I felt like it was a little
overrated guys right it's amazing it's
hilarious I was laughing the entire time
work north is great it's one of the best
films in the MCU my opinion a favorite
Marvel films the best Marvel movie
that's come out this year there's Thor
movie easily the best Thor movie out
there which wasn't that hard to do
Cate Blanchett is a fat ass all the
performances are great the the action is
great it's just a really fun Marvel
movie it's one of the funniest movies in
the MCU where the jokes coming a mile a
minute there were some characters that
Walker welcome but there were some
pleasant cameos as well well everyone
seems to be in pretty much the same
opinion maybe one or two of you not so
much John I have a lot of fun using this
app we are definitely using it quite
frequently so please make sure to
download the Stardust app and follow us
at the real rejects that's right and
don't forget to send us your Justice
League reactions for the next review
Amen sister
and also I want to clarify - yes I have
a Batman beanie on but I have this
Avengers shirt on so you guys don't get
too upset but it's just so funny to read
the comments I'm gonna wear a Dark Horse
shirt next time and an image
yeah this film was quite an enjoyable
movie if you look on Rotten Tomatoes
you'll see it got like a negative 5% no
one's enjoying this middle one unpopular
opinions I'm going against the grain no
this is Marvel's third film this year
and guardians of the galaxy - while I
got amazing reviews as well John and I
we enjoyed it we weren't the biggest
fans of it we also saw spider-man
homecoming which was really fun really
hilarious films this movie to me gave me
everything I could have wanted it to be
yeah it was the best of all three Marvel
films that came out this year in my
personal opinion they've made Thor into
just a flat-out comedy it really is this
is really tight I say his name Tyco
white tee tee yeah okay it's more of a
teiko y TT film inside of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe than it is hiring
some guy just to direct another Thor
movie yes this really feels like his own
it's it's got his brand of humor if
you've seen films like what we do in the
shadows he also still implements
everything you want from an MCU film
including awesome spectacle and awesome
visuals throughout and that's why I love
this one the most out of all three
Marvel movies that came out this year
because it gave me a lot of humor which
Marvel is known for and it also gave
some really bomb action sequences and
some really beautiful visual imagery
that he would mix up yes you get to
visit Asgard again but you get to
explore a lot of different areas and you
spend a lot of time on this new planet
called Sekar it's just like they do the
garbage dump of the universe all the
buildings are really like tight and
packed together and look like they're
assembled at a junk and there are junk
heaps everywhere and everybody is kind
of a bunch of different people wearing
masks beautiful junk it's like a
Technicolor trash yeah yeah and then
there's also some moments where they toy
around just with artistic imagery
there's one point where Loki does his
whole like let me read into your mind
and you get this like beautiful
dreamlike sequence that you do see
images of in the trailer and I was
wondering if they slowed it down for the
trailer but one that you've seen in the
movies no it is slowed down and
looks amazing yeah it's this tableau
style shots that just look like
paintings man they just look like
classic ya know the images you used to
see like reading the legends of gods
fighting yeah it looks just like that
therefore the comic book age there's
just so much to rave about with what
makes this film so great I find my flaws
of the swim only come out and nitpicked
I'd rather go over like everything I
really loved and that's really the
characters and the cast assembled here
the cast here elevates what's already
really good written material for these
characters you really get an impression
right off the bat from the very opening
of this film that Thor has already been
reinvented because of his humorous style
he's much more laid-back more relatable
his dynamics that he has it pretty much
anyone that he interacts with it's less
I'm a God just seems more like a
relatable dude with it still those
layers of royalty behind him well he's
still like a boisterous warrior child in
a way I feel like Thor probably knows
he's not that special in terms of the
universe anymore because everyone's a
special thing now yeah that gives the
movie a whole new vibe a whole new Sheen
and it opens up the cornucopia of humor
that flows forth from prison yeah cuz
he's so funny and he's hilarious in this
film this still has a great ensemble
assemble not everyone gets equal amount
of screen time but whenever they were
there they they serve a really strong
impression they're a great service to
the film everybody really proves why
they're there everybody gets a moment to
shine at least and what I will
definitely say though is that this is
still Chris Hemsworth's movie you look
at films like Captain America's Civil
War which have a pretty big ensemble of
characters and you're like yeah at the
end of the day it's really caps movie I
guess but when this movie ends you're
like now that was Thor's movie doors
movie but the ensemble is still
absolutely fantastic in the film and
Chris Hemsworth absolutely nails it I
love the reinvention of Thor's
personality as he was that character I
didn't really care as much for it makes
you want to watch more of Thor I don't
know how accurate it is to the comic
books I don't really care because I just
love what Chris Hemsworth is doing now
y-yeah honestly this had the freshness
and the fun that I wanted out of
guardians to that I didn't get out of
guardians to I'll admit I was one of
those people in the audience and this
might have to do with the fact that my
has been raining all days but the first
like 20 minutes of this film I was
having a hard time readjusting to a
different vibe and flare of this type of
movie because it's so opposite from the
last couple times I've seen Thor in the
MCU the whole vibe not just Thor is
different but the entirety of it feels
very different it feels much more like a
a comedy however even when I was having
a harder time readjusting to it I was
aware in the moment that once I've
readjusted I'm probably going to really
enjoy the hell out of this movie and
sure enough I did I was already enjoying
it but I was starting to really love it
once you do get that Hulk introduction I
heard Mark Ruffalo say in an interview
with that you know it's fun that he gets
to play two different characters this
time and at first I was like isn't that
what you've always been doing then you
watch the movie you're like oh I get
what it mean because the Hulk has
probably as much if not more screen time
than Bruce Banner does yeah and he talks
quite a lot in this film he has a
personality now beyond just rage monster
they spend a lot of time just Hulk and
Thor for a little while bantering back
and forth and like Hulk and Banner are
aware of each other yeah and they have
opinions about each other you know and
they could be played against each other
in theory he's a great supporting
character in this movie the whole and
what I really loved about it was when he
when it's Hulk and Thor it's fantastic
and when it's hulking Banner that's also
fantastic yeah man Mark Ruffalo really
brought it on both ends of this really
did you could tell that he really
brought a performance for the Incredible
Hulk this time around that fight
sequence that they do teased a lot in
the trailer is really cool there's
there's other fights in this movie that
are cooler it's still a rewarding scene
and there's more layers to that sequence
than maybe what the trailer was alluding
at this was one movie where I definitely
felt that sense of like oh cool the
trailer laid out a lot of dots but the
way they all connected I wasn't
necessarily expecting and a lot of those
dots had a lot more around them that I
expected cate blanchett as hella oh
she's a fantastic villain and a
fantastic performance this is easily the
sexiest I've ever found cate blanchett I
never really have found her to be all
that sexy I know some people are like I
love Cate Blanchett I never have but
when she shows up in this movie you're
like whoa she is really hot
yeah yeah I found cate blanchett
attractive generally speaking but yeah
this is the first time I was like oh and
not that age is a problem but it also
did feel like did you like lose 30 years
of age yeah I didn't look like a G aging
or didn't look like any trickery without
I was like you you look great
what's your regimen I want to know she
plays hell up perfectly yeah I thought
she probably had one of the more
challenging aspects of the film oh yeah
which anybody who is playing a villain
in a Marvel movie now has kind of a
challenging role to play because that's
the big thing beyond that though when
you first set her up she's scary
and she's imposing and very threatening
and then she has moments that are
comedic later on in the movie and often
times when that happens with the villain
it can feel like here the writing of the
comedy but she handled it perfectly
every time she had to have a funny line
she nailed it it was still within the
context of the performance and never
seen like she was breaking to do the
joke I don't know she's like the best
MCU villain I would put her up there
with the one of the one of the better
ones one of the few kind of complaints I
had about this was that we do check out
of the hella story after a while yeah so
I figured like it could have used a
little more focus on her but I thought
everything she did was terrific and she
embodied the character really well and
what we did see if the character was
better than a lot of the other Marvel
villains we've seen of late yeah I know
so without giving away the plot and its
details there's a little there's a lot
of reveals that kept happening
throughout the movie that I'm like whoa
they do not give that away in the
trailer so the plot of the movie that
you can kind of pick up on the trailer
is Thor and Loki they're stuck on a
planet called Sekar and that's the
dumpster place we were talking about
earlier but while that's going on hella
is unleashing Ragnarok she's destroying
Asgard and taking over it so Thor's
whole goal is to try to escape so he can
yes and save the day when hella first
shows up in the movie her scene and when
she finally arrives on Asgard everything
leading up to that I did get that
feeling in my heart of woe
how are they gonna beat this person this
is pretty scary actually the problem
that occurs is about after the midpoint
of the film something very specific
starts to happen because there
a good job of balancing throw us a car
and then hell on Asgard and then about
halfway through you kind of know check
in with hello very much yeah yeah I want
to forget about it because I'm sick are
they're reminding you about it but
you're not really spending time there so
the effect of her becomes lessened over
time she becomes sort of a subplot for a
while where you're still checking back
in but the main villain for a little
while at least feels like just the
circumstances yeah trying to get to
Asgard in the first place Loki being in
the film Tom Hiddleston he does the god
of mischief better than anyone else some
people were saying like he feels
different in this tomb always cracks
jokes and oh he's funny yeah and over
the course of several movies like that
character has to grow and change yeah
you know we've done this a few times oh
we've seen Loki in more than just Thor
movie yeah you know so it makes sense to
me that he would grow a bit yeah at the
same time though being the god of
mischief you do still that you still go
back and forth with like which side are
you are yeah it still does a good job
doing that and now that the word is all
loosened up now yeah the chemistry and
the banter between him and Loki is even
better than it's ever been
oh yeah I almost buy them Maura's
brother that's is the truth now I'm like
oh you guys totally bicker like brothers
are some scenes in this movie where I'm
where I really finally was just feeling
the brother dynamic between these two
and really felt it and even in their
scenes with Odin even even when they
have any napkins I was like I see the
family here yeah Odin is not really in
the film all that much and Odin is
probably the only one they didn't amp up
humour for I don't think it's a single
joke in this movie actually they kept
serious and that was a good choice yeah
because most of the film keeps it pretty
light most of the film's pretty funny
Odin's that character they keep very
serious for a specific purpose and it's
very effective what I found super
impressive about this film is there's a
large variety of characters in here and
there's more I want to mention I never
got the impression that they were wasted
Talent call replace scourge scourge
won't give him away too much of what he
is but he's very opposite from what you
might expect for a Karl Urban role to be
do you see the trailer
caller it's gonna be yeah yeah then you
watch like the second you see him on
screen you see whose character is it
threw me off yeah yeah that was it's
funny because he is and isn't what you
expected all at the same time that's
kind of a clever trick that the likes of
which are all over this yeah yeah like
those clever little twists like this is
kind of what you thought but not exact
Tessa Thompson as Valkyrie starring Tom
Cruise yeah when I saw the trailer for
this I did not expect what that
character was gonna be and she walked
all over that screen man she commands
that yeah so so hang tight Laird yes
she's awesome in this yeah and they
never have to do something we're like
okay let's give her like a random
monologue here so you care about her you
know yeah it's all and they don't do
that with any character it's so spread
out her performance there are times
where she's just super badass or at
times where she doesn't seem like she's
on her game there are times where she's
having fun she's like Han Solo man she's
yeah drinking and getting in fights and
doing scavenging stuff and she has good
history as she has great chemistry with
Hulk and with Thor as well now I'm
excited to see more of her she's a
character I wouldn't mind seeing like a
some micro spin-off all last but not
least Jeff Goldblum as the Grandmaster
he's a character they because he's Jeff
Goldblum and he put him in the trailer
you're probably gonna want to see more
screentime of them I know I'm repeating
myself here there's enough go blue
there's an there's just enough that's
what I felt was right about everything
when I keep saying they all no one felt
wasted yeah is he's not necessarily have
like as much screen time as other
characters but when he's there he's
super effective and he's doing his
Goldblum thing he's dude he's the
Goldblum doubt in this movie on Goldblum
yeah he really is he's clearly having so
much fun with it but he's also committed
to what the performance is yeah he's
great
in the movie I thought he was great
everyone in this film is great when his
interplay with Chris Hemsworth is pricey
yes a lot of it yeah and I gotta give
this film query on it's editing cuz I
note
Tiki Watts likes to he likes let his
actors improvise and there are certain
lines that really got me where I can
step out and go that felt like this was
probably part of the improvisational
stuff that's that's a Tiki Watts right
there
however this film is edited so well that
oftentimes you watch movies like take
the Ghostbusters roommate for example or
take any Judd Apatow movie yeah they
just slice us together in the editing
room once they let all their actors
improvise this movie's edited so well
with its great dialog that there are
times really I don't know what's
improvising what's not hey yeah
something that I noticed when I when I
first watched what we do in the shadows
I was like this feels so off-the-cuff
and yet somehow unlike you know a lot of
American comedies this style yeah
nothing ever felt overplayed or like a
joke got beat into the studio's right
height yeah and that carries directly
over here there was a lot going on in
this movie it's lightly woven it it's a
it's a juggling act all the way through
and it for the most part sticks it this
movie could have been a mess not too
long and it is like a little over two
hours but ya feel like and it has a lot
of rewarding stuff in the fan out the
whole phone there's a lot of rewarding
stuff but in the finale there's great
arcs there's great developments in to
Thor's journey a lot of the characters
journey into what this means for the MCU
leading up to infinity war I thought it
was one of the best MCU movies I've ever
seen I'm glad they save this one for
last yeah all three of these I'm like
this marble is rated essentially three
comedies and this is the one they gave
me this sci-fi 80 spectacle of guardians
a lot of the great humor from spider-man
my knees point to this movie yeah and
the music and it was great too sometimes
composed sometimes it's straight
throwback music themed music from other
things that we've heard in like popular
movies I can't sit here and tell you
specifically why they went with 80s
theme I can't because 80s nostalgia is
in perhaps that might be it I mean it's
really if you look at it I gotta imagine
a lot of the people making a lot of the
major motion pictures now grew up in the
eighties yes which is why we have this
nostalgia boom you know yeah that makes
sense and so that's probably the best
way I could justify it because I'm not
like watching it going yeah Thor belongs
because like guardians is easy to
justify because star-lord
loves those 80s and now so that makes so
much sense with here I'm like yeah so I
can't justify specifically why all I can
tell you is it worth
well because it borrows the the Tambor's
of the 80s without borrowing a direct
rep because the thing guardians like
references the 80s aggressively and this
movie doesn't even though buddy has a
tee style yeah it's got the colors and
it's got some of the synth sounds and
stuff and some of the you know
oscillations between wacky or things and
more serious things but it's not
throwing stuff in your face and even the
most recognizable song is not an 80s
song see mine it picks with the film are
so specific that they would be spoilers
while I think there's great arguments to
be had with those nitpicks I would have
to save them for the spoiler review when
it comes ease big Hollywood films you
gotta always weigh your pros yeah yeah
sure I'll find some cons whatever it's
not without fault in certain areas
however it doesn't ever ruin the the
entirety of the scene even when it takes
place yeah yeah I mean I've found this
to be super tight super enjoyable and
like you it gave me everything that I
wanted I think everybody's good in it
it's really well shot the music's great
the comedies good and instead of a Thor
it got me so happy to be like yes of
Thor I really cared about Thor I really
wanted him to succeed and I feel like
I've heard some people say like it's a
straight comedy and I don't feel that's
true either I feel like it's a funny
superhero movie it's yeah it's a
superhero movie with a lot of sense of
humor but it also has all the sci-fi and
all yes superhero stuff you want because
the action in it is incredible yeah it
sort of reinvigorates not only a
franchise that needed it but also just
tropes and seams of a superhero movie in
general like everything pops yeah for
the most part if I were to score this
out of 10 I would give it like probably
a nine or nine point five out of ten
give it a nine yeah solid nine nine I
feel like over time I'm probably gonna
you just call it ten over ten alright
guys well that's our review of Thor
Ragnarok thanks for tuning in hopefully
you made it to the end of this video
appreciate you being here love you love
you love you sir you like everybody else
who hated Thor Ragnarok and we're the
only ones I liked it apparently yes are
you on our Lonely Island or a Lonely
Island here is the word out your
favorite one should Tiki watts direct
all the MCU movie pieces clearly that is
that's what we've learned from
yeah hey guys subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell you can follow us on social media
links in the description box please make
sure to go check out our patreon we're
trying to do as much content as we can
right now and we're doing having a lot
of fun posting content on patreon as
well so summer patronage Ekta day and of
course follow us on the stardust app at
the real rejects and make sure to send
us your reactions for the upcoming
Justice League movie it's gonna be just
as good as this more that one I'll wear
a thor hat and a Batman